my name is Jason gaitonde and I'm very
excited to be telling you about our work
on budget pacing in repeated auctions
this is Joint work with Yin Kai Lee Bar
Light Brendan lucier and Alex lipkins
so to motivate the results in this paper
I want to first talk about online
advertising when a user searches for a
keyword on a search engine like Google
or Bing what will happen is that
advertisers will take in data about that
keyword and some other user features and
then they'll determine how much they
want to bid for the right to show you
their advertisement and the goal of this
is they want you to click on their link
and potentially buy whatever they're
selling so for instance if a user
searches for watches you might see
advertisements from advertisers like
apple or Chanel or Kohl's
because of the frequency of these
keyword searches online advertising is
now increasingly dominating the
marketing landscape so here's just a
couple of plots showing how the growth
of Revenue has exploded in the last two
decades for companies like Google and
Facebook and nowadays they're in the
hundreds of billions of dollars
the way we can think about these ads is
you can think about them as being
allocated by repeated auctions for each
keyword that is searched you can think
of this as a new repeated auction
and so what advertisers do is as I said
they're going to submit bids to this
internet platform to determine uh
whether they will actually be displayed
as part of this View and also these bids
will determine what prices they have to
pay to show their advertisement and note
that as I said these bids can vary by
their keyword they'll vary by what users
are showing them in particular what sort
of features they have so different
searches will have different values to
the advertisements but for an Advertiser
they can't think of each auction
completely in isolation typically they
will have a binding Global budget
constraint that will constrain how much
they can spend over the course of a
entire campaign
and this campaign management is actually
a very complicated task because as I
said of the frequency of these searches
and there's a variety of options like in
payments and different ad formats and
different kind of contexts that can
appear to them
so the key practical and theoretical
challenge in understanding these
settings is how do advertisers optimally
allocate budgets across time
in the learning theory Community this
would be considered a special case of
what's called Bandits with knapsacks
because they need to choose how to bid
at each time and they're subject to a
global knapsack constraint namely their
budget
because this is a very difficult task
for those Dimensions that I mentioned
major online platforms are nowadays
providing automated budget Management
Services that'll help advertisers adjust
campaign parameters on their behalf
and this is kind of what it looks like
what advertisers will do is they'll
declare preferences and constraints so
for instance quantities like their
budget and how much they're willing to
bid in total for any given advertisement
and then they'll give this information
to an automated bidder or a bidding
algorithm and that automated bidding
algorithm is going to take in that
information and they're going to take in
the values they have for each impression
and they'll map it into bids then an
auction will be run to see which
advertisements are allocated and then
the automated bidder will see the
outcomes of these auctions
and then they'll use that input to
update their campaign details so they'll
change their bidding strategy and at the
end of The Campaign The Advertiser will
see the results of this automated bidder
in terms of their total spend and the
aggregate results
and so because of this is a very
flexible scheme and it particularly
lowers the barrier of entry for
advertisers these bidding agents are now
near universally adopted across all
mature advertising platforms
but because of the success of these
bidding agents we now have some very
pressing theoretical and practical
questions
the first one is what can we say about
the aggregate Market outcomes when all
the advertisers are using these
automated bidding agents in particular
what kind of outcomes arise and how good
are they when all advertisers are doing
this
moreover can we identify a class of
algorithms that will both achieve good
individual guarantees for any given
Advertiser as well as good Aggregate and
overall market performance
so in our work what we show is that the
answer to these two questions is yes
namely what we show is that a class of
what we call gradient-based pacing
algorithms
will satisfy both optimal aggregate
guarantees in terms of overall market
efficiency and they will simultaneously
provide strong individual guarantees for
each individual Advertiser
and I will explain these terms a little
bit more in detail in a couple slides
but when I say these aggregate
guarantees I'm talking about some notion
of overall welfare and in particular
we'll be talking about something called
liquid welfare which is kind of a
standard notion of welfare in these
budgeted settings
and one thing I want to stress now and
I'll emphasize the importance later on
is that our results are going to hold
without any convergence of these
learning algorithms and this stands in
stark contrast to kind of previous
equilibrium analyzes of these kinds of
settings
and I'll also mention this later on but
all of our results are going to hold for
a wide range of auction formats
including the standard ones that you may
have heard of like first price second
price and generalized second price
so before I can get into the formal
model and kind of tell you our results
in a bit more detail I want to quickly
talk about some related work in the
setting
so repeated auctions have been studied
in many many papers and there's also a
lot of work for repeated auctions uh
with budget constraints
um I want to just talk though about the
literature that's most related to our
work which is about pacing and second
price auctions
so when these advertisers have what's
called quasi-linear utility and in
second price auctions with budgets
it turns out that there's a pure Nash
equilibrium in what's called pacing
strategies I'll explain this a little
bit more later but roughly speaking what
it's saying is that an agent can
restrict their bidding strategies to a
very simple form what they will do is
they'll take their value for the given
item at any given time and then they're
going to shade it by some shading factor
or a pacing multiplier here it's going
to be this they're going to divide by
this one plus mu K star if they're
bitter K and they're going to do this
for every single item that's up for
auction so they're going to have the
single multiplier and they're going to
use it to shade all of their bids using
their values
furthermore it's known that when you
have a pacing equilibrium in these
settings it turns out that this liquid
and Welfare that I mentioned before of
all the agents is actually at least half
of the optimal liquid welfare for any
allocation of the goods and in
particular for an optimal allocation
that tries explicitly to optimize liquid
welfare
and moreover this factor of one-half is
optimal this is not improvable
however these results are all about
equilibrium and equilibrium strategies
and even though there's this nice kind
of compact form for equilibrium
strategies in second price auctions with
this kind of utility function in
practice however agents are actually
going to have to learn how to bid
because they're going to receive their
values online and they can't just look
at them in hindsight and compute
something so agents are going to have to
learn to bid using some sort of dynamic
learning algorithm and this is going to
be the subject of our work
and this has actually also been studied
before so balcero and Gore recently
showed that this kind of gradient based
pacing will actually converge to these
optimal equilibrium multipliers that I
mentioned but they rely on certain
convexity assumptions of some Associated
lagrangian function
and this is actually a very very strong
assumption that it's not clear whether
it's reasonable to assume it or not
and in particular for General
evaluations of the goods by the
different advertisers it turns out that
Computing these equilibrium pacing
multipliers is what's called ppad hard
which is just some complexity class but
the the upshot is that you should not
expect any efficient algorithm to
converge to these equilibrium
multipliers and therefore what this
result is saying is that we shouldn't
just take this convergence of learning
to uh equilibrium multipliers for
granted
what our work though shows is that this
gradient-based pacing that we'll
introduce in a second it still obtains
this optimal liquid welfare guarantee
even without converging to equilibrium
multipliers so remember that because of
this equilibrium guarantee if it were
the case that learning converges to
equilibrium then we would get this one
half of the optimal liquid welfare
however because of this hardness result
we know that potentially this cannot
happen but our work shows is that
nonetheless these learning algorithms
will still get the same uh liquid
welfare guarantees even without
requiring convergence of the Dynamics
and so with that kind of in mind I can
now tell you about our model
so the model of repeated auctions is as
follows we're going to have capital T
rounds and a platform is going to sell a
unit of some good at each round so think
of it as for instance in our example the
right to show your advertisement to a
new user
we're going to have n advertisers each
with an Associated Auto bidder and each
Advertiser is going to have some budget
b sub I for the ith Advertiser and this
budget cannot be exceeded over the
course of these T rounds of auctions
the way that the values are going to be
generated for The Advertiser at each
time is we're going to say that the
values v1t through VNT at time T is
drawn from some distribution capital F
independently across time however we're
allowing these values to be correlated
across components
and so what each agent's going to do is
they're going to see their realized
valuation so Agent K will see V sub k t
and they're also going to see you know
the past results of these previous
auctions and they're going to use that
information somehow to submit a bid
which we'll call B sub k t
and then what the auction is going to do
is it's going to take in those bids
we'll collect them into a vector B1 sub
T b1t through BNT and what the auction
is going to do is it's going to allocate
x sub K T units of the good to H and K
and it's going to charge P sub k t uh
price as payments for their allocation
and these payments are going to be
non-negative
now these functions x sub K T and P sub
K T they will depend on the specific
auction format so for instance if you've
heard of first price auctions uh the x
sub K T it'll be one if you're the agent
that submitted the highest bid
and the price you will pay is exactly
the bid that you submitted and the
second price auction the allocation rule
will be the same but the price you will
pay if you're the winning bidder is
going to be the second highest price
uh so with that model of uh of the these
repeated auctions let me now tell you
our notion of aggregate welfare
as I mentioned this before it's known as
liquid welfare and an agent's liquid
welfare for an allocation is just what
their maximum willingness to pay for the
allocation is including their budget
constraints
so a bit more mathematically given this
sequence of valuations V and a sequence
of allocations x
the liquid value obtained by an agent K
is the following
in this sum over here the sum of this x
sub K T and V sub K T this x sub K T and
V sub K T their product is measuring how
much of the good and how much value per
unit good that the agent is getting at
time t so each summon here is telling
you how much value the agent is getting
from this allocation and given their
valuations at time T and then the sum is
just taking it over all time
this is how much they would be willing
to pay for their allocation if they had
no budget constraints whatsoever
however because they're only able to pay
for their allocation up to their budget
we take the minimum of their budget and
this uh this sum over here
so that's the liquid value obtained for
a single agent and then we'll say that
the liquid welfare of some allocation
sequence X for all bidders is just going
to be the sum across bidders of their
liquid values for the allocation
and this is the sort of welfare notion
we're going to be studying in the rest
of this talk
and now let me tell you what pacing
means as I've mentioned a couple times
so all pacing is is a very convenient
and simple class of linear bidding
strategies and I'll I'll describe it a
bit more in just a second but these
strategies have very strong theoretical
properties some of which I mentioned
from this previous literature
and the idea is extremely simple each
bitter K is just going to maintain some
pacing multiplier which we'll call MU
sub K T at each time T and this is going
to be some number that's at least zero
and they're going to use this number to
shade their values to give their bid at
a given time and in particular what
they're going to do is they're going to
take their value at time T and they're
going to divide by 1 plus mu sub KT and
remember because this pacing multiplier
is non-negative they're really just
lowering their value to give their bid
so this is a very convenient class of
linear bidding strategies because it's
parameterized by a single number and you
just take your value and multiply by
this number to obtain your bid at any
given time
and so what do pacing algorithms do
well let's let P sub t as before denote
the round T expenditure of some agent
and let's write rho to be their budget
divided by the total time this is their
target spend rate as if they could
completely smooth out their spending
they would want to spend this much per
round
and so what they'll do is if they're
expenditure in the given round is at
least this target spend rate what
they'll do is they'll increase this
multiplier mu sub t plus 1 for the next
round and the effect of this is in their
bidding strategy it'll increase the
denominator here and it'll make them
shade more uh shade more and in
particular they'll bid less aggressively
in the next round
if on the other hand their expenditure
is less than their target spend rate
they'll decrease uh this multiplier
uh and the effect of this is it'll
actually lower the denominator which
will make this bid go up in the next
round so they will bid more aggressively
that's all we mean by pacing algorithms
now gradient based pacing is just a
particular instantiation of this that's
been studied in the literature like I
said from this balcero and Gore work and
the idea is just given some learning
rate Epsilon we're going to update mu T
in this previous scheme using some very
concrete updates in particular we'll
take the previous multiplier and we'll
subtract off Epsilon times this
difference between the target spend rate
and the actual expenditure in the
previous round and all we'll do is we'll
just project it back onto the
non-negative numbers to make sure that
this pacing multiplier is indeed greater
or equal than zero and this is called
gradient-based pacing because you can
interpret this difference between the
target spend rate and the current round
expenditure as a sort of gradient for
some lagrangian function
and so this is exactly how we're going
to do the updating of the multipliers
and so with all of this notation Now set
I can tell you about our main result on
aggregate welfare of gradient based
pacing
so the theorem is as follows let's fix
any what I'll call a core auction which
I'll say a bit more about in a second
but it includes all these important
classes like first price second price
and generalized second price
and let's fix any distribution capital F
over the agent value profiles that show
up at each round
and now let's suppose that each agent is
going to use this gradient-based pacing
algorithm I just described to bid
and let's write X to be the
corresponding valuation or the
corresponding allocation rule that would
be obtained uh if all agents use this
gradient based pacing so in particular
this x is going to be a random variable
because it depends on the realization of
values drawn from this capital f
what we show though is that if you take
any other allocation rule why we have
the following guarantee we have the
expected liquid welfare obtained through
this gradient based pacing by all the uh
by all the advertisers is going to be at
least a half of the expected liquid
welfare obtained under this completely
arbitrary allocation sequence y up to
some sublinear term over here so in
particular what we're saying is that
this gradient-based pacing is attaining
at least a half of the best possible
liquid welfare that could be obtained
for the realized sequences of values in
expectation
and so like I said this core auction
there's some technical definition but I
just want to say it's a very large class
that includes first price second price
and generalized second price auctions
this result is allowing for arbitrary
correlation across values in a given
time period for the agents
and just to reiterate this result and
this factor of one-half over here is the
optimal liquid welfare guarantees that
you could obtain even for offline
equilibrium strategies but as we said
before because we're now studying these
learning algorithms we do not require
any convergence at all to equilibrium
and we're still getting this optimal
liquid welfare guarantee up to the
sublinear term
so we've shown some really nice
aggregate guarantees of these
gradient-based pacing algorithms and
from a platform's perspective that's
really important because it's saying
kind of the market is relatively
efficient
um but then why should any given
Advertiser use it to justify that we
need to provide some stronger individual
guarantees like we can say for a given
Advertiser it's doing something well to
maximize your own welfare
so we also supplement this aggregate
guarantees with a new individual
guarantees for this gradient-based
pacing with respect to the objective of
value maximization which is a standard
objective in online markets
and so the setting is as follows for
these results suppose that for a given
Agent K their value V sub K T and the
competing bids B minus case T are drawn
from some distribution G at each time T
so this is a stochastic environment
because we're assuming that the
competing bids are drawn from some
distribution possibly correlated with
their own uh with the agent's values
uh we're gonna also assume that we're in
what's called a monotone bang per Buck
auction so informally all we're kind of
saying is that the value of the goods
you obtain for your unit spend is
decreasing in your bid and this is a
property that's kind of very natural and
it holds in all these settings we've
mentioned before first price second
price generalized second price
and so our main theorem for individual
guarantees is the following
let's let capital Y of mu denote the
expected value of the bidding strategy
that just bids using mu as the pacing
multiplier so at each given time pretend
that you were to bid be uh your bid is
just your your value divided by one plus
mu until you run out of your budget
what we show is that for any mbb auction
the value of the goods that is obtained
by this gradient-based pacing strategy
uh with the step size of order one over
root T is going to be at least the best
uh of this y of mu over any multiplier
mu up to some no regret term which is uh
t to the three quarters so this in
particular this is Vanishing uh in
average if you average over time
and so what I want to say is this is
giving some new individual guarantees
for Value maximization that extends uh
prior no regret guarantees for second
price auctions with quasi-linear
utilities and in particular we extend it
to kind of any mbb auction uh and this
is for the goal of value maximization
which is also a very important objective
um and so with the remaining time what I
want to do now is just give a brief
proof sketch of uh the first result I
showed you which is this aggregate
aggregate welfare result
so let's recall the statement of this
result it was uh for any core auction
and any distribution capital F over the
agent values uh suppose that all agents
use this gradient-based pacing then for
any other allocation rule why we know
that the expected liquid welfare
obtained when all agents use gradient
based pacing is at least a half as what
would be obtained if we allocated using
this arbitrary rule y up to some
sublinear terms and remember this was an
optimal Factor
um so just to give a very very brief uh
glimpse of what the proof kind of looks
like the key idea is that what we're
going to do is we're going to track the
evolution of these pacing multipliers
over time so in this figure uh remember
the pacing multipliers go from zero to
Infinity
um so pretend we have plotted them and
you know we plot them over time and we
plot the evolution of the muse
what we're going to say is let's call an
Epoch to be an interval uh T1 through T2
we're going to call it an Epoch if the
pacing multiplier is equal to zero at
the start of the epoch and it's strictly
positive for every other uh every other
number in this interval so we've drawn
uh in the in this highlighting the
epochs in this uh evolution of news
and so what one can show using the form
of this gradient-based pacing is that on
any Epoch your spend on average is
approximately this target spend rate row
which is budget over time uh times the
length of this epoch
and this comes kind of from the
definition of the gradient-based pacing
and so with a lot of work what we can do
is we can show that you can kind of get
this win-win analysis and it kind of
reasons as follows if your pacing
multiplier is strictly greater than zero
often you know this this plot would be
kind of shaded a lot in terms of epochs
um then the agent must be spending a lot
by the Lemma and in that case we can
actually lower bound the liquid welfare
obtained by the agent
on the other hand if this pacing
multiplier is equal to zero often that
agent it might not be spending much but
they are bidding their true value and
each time just given the if you remember
the definition of mu
and in particular that means whether or
not this agent is winning the item some
bidder must be paying this value
um in a core auction
and what we can show is using these core
auction properties uh that we can also
show that there's High liquid welfare
and we kind of show that no matter what
this Evolution looks like we can kind of
get this win-win analysis and get this
optimal Factor at one half
um and so with that I just want to
conclude with a few uh future research
directions uh so one is kind of can you
generalize this result to broader
classes of learning algorithms Beyond
this gradient-based pacing and also kind
of what's the interplay between these
individual guarantees and liquid welfare
guarantees can you kind of improve one
while keeping the other
um in non-truthful auctions like first
price auctions you can ask for you know
better regret bounds than this t to the
three quarters
um you can ask for regret with respect
to uh you know stronger benchmarks than
what we mentioned which was kind of this
best pacing multiplier in hindsight
um and also you can ask about whether
you can uh make these algorithms uh that
the auto bidders are using robust to the
case where advertisers are also being
strategic so they know the strategies
that the auto vendors are using they
might be tinkering with the auction
format can these Auto bidder algorithms
uh be made robust to these kind of
strategic considerations
so just a reminder of the key takeaways
what we do is we show them when all
agents are simultaneously applying this
gradient-based pacing we show that the
liquid welfare obtained over the course
of these Dynamics is at least half of
the optimal expected liquid welfare and
remember this half is optimal
and as I stressed before our result does
not require any convergence of these
Dynamics whatsoever and it'll hold for
any core auction which is kind of a very
broad class of options
uh and also like I said you know these
algorithms are not just giving these
good aggregate guarantees they're also
giving these very strong individual
guarantees that justifies their use for
any given Advertiser in terms of these
no regret performance bounds uh with
respect to the best fixed pacing
multiplier in hindsight
and with that thanks so much